in the most recent attack on titan
episode a question was posed among the
survey corps
of who would inherit aaron's titans the
titans in question being of course
the founding the attack titan and
warhammer titan or as i like to call it
the
absolutely unstoppable trio this guy
can't be stopped he even says it himself
to hanji
he was already beating the rest of the
game with two titans but he really said
y'all thought i was finished
[Music]
you thought it was over and said happy
early christmas by turning galliard into
your mom's favorite nutcracker
but i digress let's return to the main
topic at hand which is
of course who will inherit these powers
that's if anyone gets them at all
or whether they die with aaron in the
few years he has left because of ymir's
13-year curse
and though we would of course love to
see one of our favorite survey corps
members inherit it
and carry the torch the real inheritor
as it has been suspected since the very
first episode of this season
is very likely to be falco and you might
be asking
well why talk about this theory now if
it's been like three months since the
first episode of season four
well i mean to be honest
i just forgot and this discussion in
episode 69
reminded me to do it taking into
consideration the vision of the survey
core he saw
the way it mirrors aaron's introduction
and essentially the elimination of
almost anyone else possibly receiving it
here's why we know falco will inherit
his titans
and before i get any further i do want
to mention that these are all just my
opinions it's things that i've gathered
and things that i think are gonna happen
based on what i've watched and what i've
read so let's get into it
falco saw a vision of the survey corps
in the first episode of season four
something that he of course would only
be able to do as some kind of
premonition of being a titan shifter
someday
he had a vision of quote unquote flying
around presumably on odm gear
and killing titans this eliminates zeke
and peak as
options of people who he eats because
they've of course never
been in this kind of situation before
however this could still be any of the
other seven titans since all of them
have been held by the survey corps
member at some point
even though the jaw titan is currently
held by porco it has amir's memories
the colossal has armins and birdholtz
the armored has reiners
female has annies and the warhammer
slash founding
attack titan will collectively have
aaron's memories
but what's most important here other
than declaring that falco won't get the
beast titan or cart titan
which i mean did we really think he
would is the way that this vision in the
first episode of season four
mirrors aaron's introduction in the very
first episode of
well season one just as aaron was first
introduced
after being woken up from a vision a
premonition of the future where his mom
was being eaten
falco is having the very same thing the
fact that he's seeing memories of some
titan before even owning a titan himself
the very first time he's introduced is
very purposefully meant to parallel
aaron's story
i mean these are the only two times
we've seen someone see visions of the
future
only with these two characters which is
interesting
because gabby's origins and character
arc so far in the season
also very much mirror errands i think
the reason that gaby's similarities to
aaron have been made so much more
obvious than falco's so far is because
well it's meant to distract us from the
real character who will relive aaron's
legacy
falco has been trusted to save gabby
from her fate by reiner
and thus simply because of the themes of
history having repeated cycles of
violence
the responsibility extends to falco also
saving
aaron and the world from this future as
well
which might be some big steps but let's
go further into detail
into this theory let's eliminate some
other options as well
jon was right in saying that we don't
know enough about mikasa's origins
in the azumabito clan to see whether she
could inherit a titan
in fact well she can't the nation of
hizuru was stated to be allies of the
eldean empire long ago
implying that they aren't aldians
themselves and by extension they can't
be subjects of emir
which means there's no shot she's
getting a titan i mean these abs on a
titan
sheesh come on i mean we wouldn't
survive
anyway and for overkill in case you
still think she could do it mikasa is
also an ackerman
a family who was long ago immune to the
brainwashing powers of the founding
titan
which would probably interfere in some
way with her ability to inherit a titan
i i don't know if it really would but
with this on top of already being an
azumabito
she's really got no shot they wouldn't
choose armin because
well he's already got a shortened
lifespan the whole point of passing on
the titan is to extend its 13-year
warranty
in another person and while armin
definitely would be a good candidate
since he's a smart guy in everything
not only is his lifetime already on a
timer but this would consolidate four
titans into one person
which you could argue isn't bad if it's
with armin one of the most responsible
and smart people in the series arguably
the best character in this series to be
able to handle this burden
but what happens when he dies someone
will have to inherit four of the
strongest titans they'd be unstoppable
if the three without the colossal titan
could already be stopped anyway of
course
jean connie and sasha all have different
reasons not to be chosen
jean is too good of a soldier to be
forced to die in 13 years
connie's a bit of a numbskull and sasha
is a numbskull
and dead and just as is the case with
jean
hanji and levi are also simply too
important to the military infrastructure
of paradise island to be given a titan
their futures in the survey corps are
integral to the future of the island
itself
and so this essentially closes the
theory of someone close
to aaron or on paradise island as a
member of the survey corps
inheriting his titans in the event of
his death
but what if no one got it and there is a
chance
of this happening of no one receiving
the titans at the end of the story if
aaron and zeke do end up pulling off the
plan with the rumbling
indiscriminately destroying the people
of the main continent and leaving
eldians on paradise as the only
survivors
i guess there really wouldn't be a need
for the titans after there's no conflict
in the world
after all titans are basically just
human weapons
but aaron's titans are simply too great
a commodity for paradis to let
die off with the potential to beat any
enemy
defend the island should some stragglers
survive and try to fight them
or immediate conflicts within the walls
in the future
losing three of the strongest titans
isn't an option
maybe if he only had one or two i guess
aaron dying off with his titans would
kind of make sense but with three
it just seems very impossible to happen
and if it must be passed on
this is where the falco theory comes in
but is this the best way for the story
to end because it's pretty clear that
aaron's plan will bring the end of the
story
either through its fruition or maybe his
death or maybe even both who knows
i mean the manga hasn't even finished i
don't even know i could be saying
absolute bs in this video and who'd know
the better
but anyway would falco thematically be
the best choice to finish off
attack on titan this has to be
considered because
well it's the ending of one of the
biggest series of the past decade
and giving this role to someone just
because it makes sense through process
of elimination isn't at all ideal
but we have to realize that falco eating
aaron can possibly be that bridge
between the eldians and the rest of the
world
what they just declared as impossible to
reach in the recent episode
because they of course the people in
this wagon at this point
would never consider an ld for marley
inheriting the titan
falco can open up the route that they
didn't think that we didn't even think
was achievable there will of course be
other characters involved in this finale
so i don't think that falco will receive
all of the spotlight
but instead he'll probably just be one
of many integral factors to the ending
of aaron's arc
and by extension the ending of attack on
titan
would i have wanted someone else to get
it maybe i guess
but in my opinion as long as isayama
executes it all tastefully
and respects the goals and ideas of the
other main characters
while giving this fate to falco i'll be
pretty satisfied
personally i mean as long as levi ends
up killing zeke i'll be satisfied with
any ending but
you know we gotta look at it more
broadly god i hate zeke
anyway what do you guys think of this
theory who do you think will inherit the
titan how do you think it'll tie
into the end of the series i mean there
really are so many routes but i feel
like with the things we've been given in
season four
and how the story is looking from here i
feel like falco is one of the
only options left
as always this has been the anime
culture corner i hope you enjoyed the
video
don't forget to like and subscribe for
future in-depth show manga and character
analyses
you